foreign
office
you get a driver's license on you yeah
go ahead step out of the car for me man
you all right no no no no no no no no
step out of the car your foot's on the
gas okay
[Applause]
you do you know that you've been driving
on the uh the rim of your car here
foreign
did you did you get in a car accident
I hit a curb
I guess I had the curb kind of hard but
I wouldn't have expected the uh
I hit the curve the same way like we
have any uh signal threes recently the
same way making the cutbacks
honestly if you ask me
I think somebody put a curse
at the 44 probably somewhere between 200
and uh the interstate here it's gonna be
a black SUV severe damage to the
driver's side
no rooms or tires left
I had the curb a little hard but there's
no reason
that's both tires
all right is
go ahead and hop out for me man
am I in trouble right now just hop out
for me right now
all right
do you have anything on you any guns or
anything like that no I just turn around
for me I'm gonna pat you down I'm not
gonna search you got your hands up there
okay that's fine
all right come back here for me
well we gotta address a few things
nope
situations
we'll get there just one second
all right
suddenly uh
where are you coming from
um
because the code that I stay inside all
day have you had anything to drink today
no no
do you need uh ambulance for anything
I mean I was asleep at the gas station
come over here for me
it's just because I gave up I gave up on
trying to get my car to work all right
man
foreign
let's take your hat off I'm gonna run
you through some field sobriety
exercises do you agree to take those
with me
no no but you understand that if you
you
okay
I got stuff in my boots well you almost
fell over there
because uh these things make it okay
listen I suspect that you're impaired
and now I'm asking you to
perform some field sobriety exercises
out here tonight right but that wouldn't
prove anything that's just you being
like a bald headed background is that
right look at your car I watched you
from there that's drive up trying to get
on the interstate
good
[Music]
[Music]
money
hello next time I like my car on fire
and I lay down here and I'm taking a nap
and I just call it out my life you know
what I mean I suspect that you're
impaired no you don't you're just racist
and if you don't submit to some of these
exercises you're gonna end up going to
jail tonight
I feel like I'm gonna go to jail anyways
because you're racist I mean just look
at you man
I'm not really I'm not having the games
out here this morning
do you understand do you understand how
serious this is you don't understand how
serious this is
so you're gonna refuse you're not gonna
take any of these tests it's very simple
all you have to do they're very simple
exercises we'll run you through them
they help me determine signs of
imperable I'll take the test man but
you're prototype down for a cop this is
so right all right so are you ready
yes or no I'll take the test I'll take
the test but know this this isn't a
bargain I'm not out here to bargain with
you man I'm not bargaining either I'm
not bargaining either I told you I was
going to take the test all right I'm not
asking any I'm not asking give me a
favor
I'm giving you information you set your
heart down I'm giving you information
stuff over here for me if you mess with
me right now sir we're not gonna stand
out here all morning so you're right now
call me so we can start running through
some of these exercises it's gonna take
about five seconds you mess with me
right now
what did you say and pick this up step
over here for me
what's up because you're on a warning
right now with your bald head and your
wife
stand right here sir you too now yellow
line accomplish head honcho you messed
this up you messed this up man put your
feet together for me you messed this up
I'm gonna break your head with a
baseball bat put your feet together so
you better keep it straight
what's your name put your feet and Toes
together for me what's your name
arms down by your side so you're the
ghost huh do me a favor you're the ghost
Nazi take a look at the tip of those
pins skin you alive if you fuck this up
look at the tip of this you better do
this by the book you hear me
what's your name
we'll get there
Deputy Wilson from Marion County
Sheriff's Office I couldn't see I
couldn't even see that take a look at
the tip of this pen for me let me see
We're not gonna stand out here all night
you understand if you refuse to do these
exercises you're gonna go to jail do you
understand that you look like a Nazi
look at the tip of this pen for me you
better not follow it with your eyes and
own your eyes
monitor
foreign
I got a red baseball bat
a painted Circle circles on it with a
sharpie
stand in front of you spin it clockwise
you know what happens next are you
threatening me
I'm keeping you in check because you're
a Nazi all right man I want to see
something I want to see some hair here's
what we're going to do we're gonna go
through the walking turn okay I'm gonna
have you walk to I'd like to do it in
front of my car I bet you if I killed
you right now
oh yeah they'd give me a medal
just have him
come on
the what the just the one leg I don't
know I mean we've got room for it on
this line plus the traffic
oh they can get by
this is level plenty level for me so
all right sir here's what we're gonna do
come down here for me please
stand in the back area of your car there
it's right here on this line
all right for this exercise I'm gonna
ask that you walk this line heel to toe
and I'm going to demonstrate the
position I'd like you to be in okay for
this exercise I'd like you to place your
left foot on the line you're going to
use the yellow line there you're going
to take your right foot place it in
front of it Heel To Toe hands down by
your side
now while I go over the instructions and
I demonstrate for you I'd like you to
maintain that position and don't start
until I tell you to okay can you go
ahead and get in position for me you
versus you man
let me know if you have any questions at
this point in time put your left foot on
the lawn for me at this point in time I
don't care if you do this straight man
I'm coming after you and then put your
right foot in front of it heel to tell
all right hands be afraid of me right
now hands down by your side and maintain
that position until I tell you to start
the exercise listen to the sound of a
taser in your ear do you have any
questions
all right for this exercise I'm going to
ask that you take nine heel to sew steps
following this yellow line
on the ninth step you're going to take a
series of small turns
until you know we're back in this
position
and then you count nine Heel To Toe
steps back in the direction you came
from it'll look so something like this
one
two
three until you get to nine you'll take
a series of small steps
back to the starting position and count
out loud doesn't matter which one that
puts it on two
three until you get to nine
see how you didn't explain it
what's your question sir do you have any
questions I'll find you that's not what
I'm asking do you have any questions
just the sign of a taser are you here
how does that make you feel you may
begin the exercise sir unless if you
don't have any questions
remember count out loud and if you step
off the lawn
foreign
you took four don't judge me with your
silence
what do you want me to do now you said
you didn't have any questions
that was not a question
remember continue the exercise until
it's complete so you didn't demonstrate
the exercise I demonstrated for you you
took four Paces I clarified that
what am I going to do now
a series of small terms
you'll get back to the original position
you started in and count nine Heel To
Toe steps back
six three 28 years before six
[Music]
all right sir
so they got one layer now yep
let's walk just in front of my car a
little bit more and have you get right
here if you would
that'll work
go ahead and place your heels and Toes
together hands down while you do this
thing nope
heels and Toes together for me
your toes together sir
good
stay just like that I'm gonna
demonstrate for you okay this is the one
leg stand what I'm gonna ask you to do
is keeping your hands down by your side
I'm gonna ask you and you can pick
either foot the foot of your choosing
I'm gonna ask you to raise it
approximately six to nine inches off the
ground just like this
I'm gonna ask you to count out loud in a
manner such as this
1001 1002 1003
1005 and so on until I tell you to stop
okay I'll be timing it if you place your
foot down just simply pick it back up
and continue until I tell you to stop
the same way you guys pretend you don't
have do you have any questions sir
family on wheelchairs do you have any
questions sir that's the same way you
just pretended like that's normal I just
did it would you like me to demonstrate
again for you yeah I know and you're
pretend you don't got a small dick and
you're pretending you don't got a
feeling do you have any questions sir
no matter if I have questions you may
begin
would you like me to demonstrate again
for you I don't want you to demonstrate
I just want you to tell me okay
you're gonna raise the foot of your
choosing approximately six to nine
inches off of the ground keeping it
parallel with the ground and count out
loud 1001 1002 1003 and so on until I
tell you to stop that's not fair because
I was never really a balanced kind of
guy I'm a rapper okay yeah I'm an
intellectual you may begin physics was
never my thing
we just worked through this man we're
almost finished we just want to do this
we're almost finished once we do this
we're finished up
and then what
you may begin how long
until I tell you to stop I'll be timing
it
remember if you place your foot down
uh-huh
stop
all right sir do me a favor turn around
you're being placed under arrest review
okay
I'm gonna double lock these so they
don't tighten up on you all right
we're here walk over here to my car for
me do you have anything on you illegal
if you take it into the jail it'll be an
extra charge
you tell us now we'll work it out here
on the side of the road
go work it out here on the side of the
road you'll still be charged with it but
you won't get an additional charge to
take the individual
don't take my pocket well we're gonna
check them for you but if it's concealed
or anything like that
well you ask them real quick
don't reach in your pockets if you've
got any kind of drugs or anything
concealed on you okay we can deal with
it now you'll get charged for it but you
don't sneak it into the jail
I was just hanging out dude you're about
to get on the interstate like this man
you're lucky you didn't kill yourself
or someone else I didn't break the law
I'm getting home what do you want me to
do camp out here
are you going back to Tampa USF area or
are you going back to Tampa yeah okay
you know you're going northbound on the
interstate right
southbound
I just did a u-turn too man I've been
waiting for the signs too I was looking
for signs
you know your signs are spread out hard
especially in that car man do you have
anything on you
but anything on you at all I'm gonna
find both of you
okay you know what andresuela means
you're mad calm right now man you're
gonna regret that I know that right
this isn't your territory
[Music]
number one
give me
y'all pull y'all pull me out of my car
I'm sorry for what
confirming here
just give me a second
four sixty one two four six
sorry
thank you
traffic
report
no
lift up my my back just so you know here
foreign
the Messiah
the Messiah
[Music]
I'm gonna make you starve your family
starve what do you got kids
a wife a daughter
a sister a son
I'm gonna break their legs raped them in
front of you pig
you should have just left it at the
field
you should have gave me a ride home
what's up
this is my word listen stop spitting man
I'm gonna put you in the car man let's
not have any more issues out here okay
you should just give me five
stop spits are like seriously
dogs
dude really
Force
see the way you do it see how it works
see how it works
see how the government works Doug
see how the government works
you gotta apply pressure